hi good luck to you both um
i just questioned for gareth just
basically
your thoughts heading into what is the
nation's biggest game
in 55 years and and the letter you
received from the queen
the end of it kind of summed up talking
about spirit commitment and pride
everything your team has
displayed this tournament yeah i mean
it's
it's been fantastic to have
um obviously the letter from the queen
letter from the prime minister to all of
the team
and the recognition that the players and
all of the staff have gone about this in
the right way
um we had a fabulous reception when we
left saint george's all the local
villages had come out and
lining the route and people pulled over
in lay-bys and
so you got more of a sense of what's
going on outside the bubble that we've
been in
but it always comes back to tomorrow you
know we're in a final and
we're we're here to um we're here to win
so everything is important how we've
represented people and we're pleased
that
that uh that legacy has been there um
but now we want to go and and bring the
trophy home for everybody
i think should have said it at the top
but just a reminder to uh specify who
you're questioning for is when you ask
we'll go next to james robson as
standard hi this question for gareth hi
gareth um tomorrow it's uh it's gonna be
a long day
leading up to to the match i was just
wondering
what does tomorrow look like you know
how do you keep the players
i suppose busy if you like it's gonna be
hard enough for the fans let alone the
players
and they've got to wait till till 8 pm
to kick off what do you do
in that time for us it's just a normal
match day we've prepared the same way
for all of our evening kickoffs
and we'll have the same uh meetings at
the same time
players will perhaps have a stretch or a
walk although that might be a bit more
difficult looking outside the hotel
so um but it
all of our preparation especially for
these knockout matches has been the same
we've had evening kickoffs each time
and i think um no matter what the game
you've got to keep that
consistency in how you prepare the
players are
ready they're tactically aware they're
used to playing in
in these games and um everybody's
looking forward to it
and i was just wondering when when
you've got the group together
um i think luke shaw said at the start
the the speech he gave was was moving
when you when you addressed everyone at
the same time so just wondering
what did you just say to them at that
point
well we presented everybody with
legacy caps which as you know we have
introduced the legacy numbers in the
last couple of years
um we felt that's been an important
thing not
just for the players that are with us
now but for our former players you know
you you
to have that moment where you've got
your number
it's unique to you there's only um
a certain number of players who've had
the opportunity to represent their
country and
so we talked a little bit about that and
how you know this was our moment to
represent
our time um what had gone before
is not unimportant because we recognize
the contribution other people have made
and
we're respectful of that but the
the near misses and the the um
the tournaments that haven't gone so
well weren't important for this team
and over the last four years they've
knocked down so many barriers and
they've
come through so many different
challenges
different ways to win matches uh had to
come back from being behind had to
go through extra time had to go through
penalty shootouts so
their resilience and experiences as a
team have really prepared them well for
this moment
thank you james next we'll take a
question from italy uh marco conterio
yeah uh hello mr softgate uh my question
is uh do you have any message for the
fans for not doing the national italian
national anthem
yes of course it's important
that our fans always respect the
opposition
and we know that in actual fact
when we play abroad and fans boo our
anthem it probably inspires us even more
so
um i don't think it will help the team
i think we can intimidate the team with
booing during the game
but um it's you know different for the
anthem i think uh
we we should be respectful
sorry marcus go again you're a follower
yeah no worry no worries
yeah my question my other question for
kenneth for hurricane
uh which are your feelings for for the
game
against uh killing me and bonucci not
the last defenders of the world
thank you yeah no of course uh they're
two
uh amazing defenders um they've had
great experience
over their careers in big matches uh
obviously i've been
uh fortunate enough to play against them
before and um
you know as a striker i want to be
playing against the best centre-backs
in the world and those two are
definitely up there um but of course
this game is not
just about me and and the two
center-backs the game is about england
vs italy and
um you know we feel like we've got a
great belief in the team
uh we've got a great um strength in
in in the squad um so yeah we there's a
lot of
things that can happen in a final and
and we need to make sure that
that we're on the right side of it thank
you marco next we'll go to arrows alsada
from vg norway
gareth please um regarding the uh
the uh much talked about
football's coming home chant and and
phrase because it seems to me like it's
being
misinterpreted outside of england as
some kind of
english arrogance and and when you go
out of the tournament
it's uh being used as a joke against you
um so i'm just wondering
as you followed this this chant for for
i guess
since 96 how do you interpret it and
what is the
the real meaning of it well
i didn't want to listen to it for 15
years because it was
too painful for me so it's um
yeah you have to know the english to
understand our humor and
um uh humor is probably quite unique
but um it's certainly not arrogant the
the the lyrics are taking
making fun of ourselves really and the
things that have gone wrong so
it has always appeared now at the
tournaments we've got
a couple of replacements that seem to
have come in now in terms of songs as
well which is nice to
keep moving things forward but it's
great the atmosphere in the ground has
been great you know wembley
the new wembley is um when
we started three four years ago we had
people throwing paper airplanes they
they weren't they weren't behind the
team they were
there was an apathy towards the team now
the energy in the stadium is
is fantastic and that's so important for
the players you know
they need to feel that they need that
warmth that support
and um it has definitely helped inspire
us during this tournament
thanks errolus next we'll go to kerry
brown being sports
um a question to you first gareth um
jeff hurst has likened your leadership
to the leadership
of sir alf ramsey um the queen has just
sent you
a message far too early on in your years
um i'm wondering how you are dealing
with reaching
an england final because the whole
nation are trying to get their head
around it
i think yeah we're very calm um
we've got a lot of belief in this group
of players and
harry and myself were just talking
earlier that we've grown into the
tournament
we knew there were different phases of
this tournament and our first objective
was to qualify from the group and
we stayed calm after the scotland game
when
you know they're the moments where
there is criticism and you can adopt a
siege mentality and change your approach
with people outside and
we were determined not to do that we
were quite
consistent in the way we carried
ourselves and went about our work
and from there it's been opportunities
to make history every time we've played
it seems so we've done that the players
have done that
and yeah we're looking forward to the
challenge it's a brilliant game
to be involved in it's a brilliant game
to prepare for because we're playing a
high-level opponent and um they're
tactically very good
um they've had a tremendous run so
that's another great challenge for us
and a question to you harry you've just
experienced
something that your coach did go through
at euro96 you've seen
all the fans on the street the nation
will take to a street for you
right now harry how do you bottle that
and you've already reached a final
you've made history but
i don't think you're done yet are you no
i mean that's the challenge now
[Music]
of course we've been knocking down
barriers along the way but
we started this tournament with a name
to win it and we have that opportunity
tomorrow night and um yeah to see the
fans on the street like they have been
and
see the reception that we've had as
we've pulled into the hotel here and as
we're just leaving st
george's park has um yeah just just
showing us how
how big an occasion it is i think in
russia obviously we was over there and
we was in our own bubble and we could
see videos of what it was like back home
but we couldn't really
uh experience it ourselves and um yeah
even
even this uh this camp obviously we've
been kind of just on to the next one on
to the next one
just focusing on the next game which
we've done for this final but it's great
to see the reception that we're getting
and
we know how much it means to the english
fans um
all over the country so we're proud to
be representing them and
hopefully we can do them proud again
tomorrow night thanks carrie
antonello guerrero la repubblica
hello everyone and good luck for uh for
tomorrow
i have a first question to you guys
um what what concerns you most i mean
they
of uh italy maybe uh kieza
is in a great form uh recently or more
the milk field because uh i mean uh how
how much
are you concerned about these three
georginio
and the others against two maybe
the least experienced players in your
team which are
rice and phillips
yeah i think um when when you're
the coaching team you you watch
everything and um
you have to decide the most important
information for the players
and not flood them with too much
try and adapt the game to our strengths
try to highlight the potential
weaknesses in the opponent
so of course there are fantastic players
all through the italian team they have a
good tactical plan um experienced coach
and an amazing record over the last 30
games
so we're very aware of that but players
like our two midfield players they've
played
beyond their experience in this
tournament and
they've already played against luka
modric tony cruz
so they've had to adapt to these types
of midfield players with
great european experience and they've
done that brilliantly we we're
different you know we um
we have our own strengths we have our
own style of play which is
geared towards the strengths of our own
players and that's the beauty of
football that every team has different
strengths and
we've tried to play to ours and adapt
our game to our strengths
and we need to do the same tomorrow
and have a uh question for have a
as well harry as a captain uh
how different is the eve of this
incredible game especially for you and
your mates i mean after
55 years and we all know that i mean
how different is um from other games and
how do you
prepare all to face this uh incredible
challenge
yeah if i'm totally honest you know
we've gone through the same preparation
as we have done the last few games you
know we've had the same amount of time
in between in terms of to recover and to
prepare and to to work on the training
field so
as soon as the game finished in the
midweek it was just
full focus onto this one and we went
through the same
strategies and the same routine that
we've gone through before so
um yeah of course there's a an extra
level of excitement
and anticipation um but that's all part
and parcel of playing
in major football so a lot of us have
played at the highest level in our in
our club
careers a few of us obviously had the
opportunity
in the world cup a few years ago so um
yeah it's just about staying
calm staying as relaxed as you can and
just look forward to being out there and
enjoying the moment as much as you can
okay next to marcelo courage tv globo
hi there first one for kerry um in the
past harry uh
connection issue there we'll jump to
james ollie espn
hello you got me yes we have yet
can you hear me do we can yet yeah um
one for harry if i can um you said
earlier in the tournament harry that you
you were trying to sort of peak in the
latter stages sort of
contrasting that to russia can i just
ask how you've actually gone about that
have
you done something differently behind
the scenes to sort of try and peak in
those latter stages
yeah i mean um obviously don't get me
wrong i'd love to have scored
three or four goals in the group stage
and got off to a fantastic start and
um been yeah gone on from there but
it was more probably about the energy i
felt like in the in the world cup
um obviously it was such an amazing
start
um starting with tunisia scoring last
minute a lot of energy after that game
was was used in terms of the emotion and
everything like that and then panama the
same we got off to
had an amazing game i scored a hatchback
and um
yeah there's a lot of talk a lot of
mental energy so um
colombia was the same and and yeah not
just physically i felt like mentally
maybe just
lost a little bit towards the the latter
stages so going into this one with a bit
more experience it's just about
not getting too carried away whether i
scored don't score
um obviously we was winning games which
was the most important thing so it's
just about
yeah just staying in the moment uh not
getting carried away just knowing that
um as a player and as a team you know
we're on the right track
um and thankfully it's worked out it's
worked out pretty well but
i guess that's all part of the learning
curve of of playing in major tournaments
and
and gaining that experience so um yeah
hopefully i've got
enough left to to finish a job tomorrow
thanks james
uh marcelo we have you back so we'll try
again okay
uh so harry first question to you uh
in the past before big matches like
these
football teams used to you know to scare
to do these mind games to scare the
opponent
but this team brings this english team
brings
such a humbleness in the narrative uh
that
it seems odd to do something like this
do do you fear trump being too friendly
to your opponents
in a in a final like this no i don't
think so i think
um obviously that's the personality of a
lot of the players in the squad they are
humble
they are respectful but i think we have
a real
focus and determination to win yeah i
think we've shown that
um in the last tournament we played and
going into this tournament
knocking down barriers that have been
there for our country for a long long
time so
um yeah i feel like in modern football
uh nowadays um there isn't so much
probably mind games before and getting
too
hyped and getting too uh out of control
you know we have a real
focus of where we want to be a real
vision of where we want to be
and yeah without without that and
without our winning mentality we
wouldn't be in a situation we are now
and for gareth uh i interviewed uh ian
brudy
who wrote three lions the it's coming
home song
two days ago and i asked him if he had
to do a new version of the song
for this team which player he's gonna
peak
uh to to put in the lyrics and then he
he mentioned harry as a super striker
but he's
told me that it should be only you
gareth
because you're the unity of this team
you you mean a lot for this team
how do you take this on i think any
manager
relies on having support
from coaches especially you know i've
got a fantastic assistant steve holland
who
we've worked for a number of years now
and i couldn't do
what i do without him but we have a big
staff
and you in modern management in any
business you can't
lead without good people around you you
need the right information the right
support
and so you know i'm fortunate to be in
that position
also we have some very good players and
uh we should never underestimate the
fact that whatever we might do
um the game's about players and we've
got some very good ones who
are highly motivated who've worked
brilliantly together
um some high-profile players who've
really accepted
perhaps not getting as much football as
they might have wanted
but they've all committed to the to the
team and they've committed to the group
and um i think our country have
realized that they've seen what that's
been about and
um they deserve to be in the position
they are now with this opportunity
thanks marcelo alex hell bbc sport
hi gareth hi alex
um just gonna ask have you allowed
yourself
um to think about what it would be like
if you managed to win this tournament i
know
you're very focused on the game but you
had a couple of moments when you thought
about what it would be like to uh
bring the trophy home no um
i mean at the back of your mind you
always have to have a
a bit of a vision of um
[Music]
how you would like to see the end um
and and play that out but the reality is
i think you've got to focus on the
processes and
focus on the performance and
that that's what we have always done
with this team and
um i think that it's important that
the players have an understanding of
that um
whatever path the game takes and it can
take any any number of different paths
football matches are like that
they're prepared and they're ready so um
it's pointless if you if you start to
think about the end or after
uh while you're while you're still
involved in the game or before the game
then
you're probably heading in the wrong
direction and we've just got to make
sure we
control the bits that we can control
thank you and then just one more uh
gareth i know you spoke to
my colleague earlier john murray had
mentioned that uh phil foden had a
slight knock
i was just wondering whether he had
there there had been chance within the
team to
assess him and whether he'll be
available for tomorrow
now as i said earlier he's a doubt um
we've been on the bus
for the last couple of hours so um
medical team will
sort of give us a final update on that
later um
but he he's definitely doubtful although
it's not something that's serious
um it's just a case of whether um
it's it's going to keep him out of this
particular game
thanks alex simon evans reuters
hi gareth um i mean obviously this being
a final
it's it's logical that this is the
strongest team you're going to face in
in
this tournament what what do you think
the team has to do
better than it's done in previous games
very good performances throughout but
to raise their game for this what areas
have you been focusing on doing better
well it's it's not necessarily about
better
it's um the challenge of every game is
slightly different
and um in finals actually
the key is to hit your normal level um
lots of teams in finals end up under
performing and
you you you don't have to find a level
beyond where you've ever gone before
it's about hitting and doing what you're
good at transferring what you do every
day on the training pitch into the match
and um i think our players know that's
our ethos they've
been in matches as harry said earlier
we've got a number who've played in
champions league finals now
a number we've been to a world cup
semi-final so
we know that those those preparations
are important
every every game is different every
opposition is different
and we always review our matches we
always look back
and and look at what we've done well and
what we could do better
um but you know this this game now is a
different
sort of tactical challenge a different
opponent and um
we've got to prepare properly for that
thank you good luck thank you thanks
simon jack pitbrook the athletic
hi gareth um the team started pretty
aggressively
in the croatia czech republic ukraine
denmark games
that started pretty nervously in the
germany game um
how do you see the start of the game
going tomorrow and how much refracted do
you think that will be
i think it's always difficult to uh
to to know that because
events can happen at the beginning of a
game you know
there can be a challenge that bounces
for somebody and
uh you know a chance can be created or
a pass can drop short and and that can
you know
affect a team for a couple of minutes so
but i think the biggest thing is that we
know that whatever happens
during the game all the players are
together
they've got colleagues who are going to
work
together to to pressure the ball they've
got
colleagues who are always going to be
available to receive the ball
um and in the moments where you have to
suffer a bit as a team
the team respond well they they dig in
together we're blessed that we have
forward players who
defend from the front and recognize the
importance of that part of the game and
um in the modern game that's so
important you you don't
carry players without the ball and that
gives you a foothold in
in games you can gain confidence from
that so
the start of course is important um and
you'd like a stable start
but the game could be 95 minutes could
be 120 we've got to make sure we're
ready for
uh however long it takes thanks jack
javier casiras yes one question for
gareth the the former premier league
coach mauricio pochettino once famously
said that
there's something particular about the
english football that the
coach always loses his team for 10
minutes due to the
pressure of the of the public they have
so much influence on the game
have you experienced something like this
uh during this tournament
which is more or less the first time
after a year without public
and um uh what are you going to do to
get your your team uh
be wearing a cold cold hat in this
match tomorrow yeah it's important for
us we
we've talked to the players for years
about
the importance of discipline on the
field
staying calm if we concede which
we knew we wouldn't go the whole
tournament without conceding and in the
semi-final
we responded really well to that moment
within a few minutes we'd created two
chances and
we were back leveling the game in in 10
minutes um
and i i think that's key
the players know especially the players
that have been with us a long time that
yes the atmosphere around you can be
intense but
um you've got to keep your focus on on
the
parts that you can control and
not be distracted by things not be not
lose heart
when when things are going against you
they're the moments you have to dig in
and
we've got a lot of leaders who are
growing in the group
um we're blessed in that regard
in the starting team and also in the in
the squad and
their voices before games during games
are really important
thanks javier and we're on to our final
question and it'll be theo squires
hi both uh got a question for each of
you i'll start with gareth um
it's quite a young england squad you've
got but since the
2018 world cup semi-final a number of
your players have been
in champions league semi-finals
champions league finals
even europa league as well but when it
comes to
making an aiming aside like this i
suppose in midfield where you're lacking
players with that experience
does that come into your thinking when
you're naming aside or is it just
they've been doing so well throughout
the tournament
there's no real reason to doubt what
they're doing
i think um
there there are benefits to having
experience of big matches and sometimes
there's benefits for it all being fresh
and exciting and
and new and um you know
declan and calvin in particular have
adapted so well
to uh to that challenge um
as i said earlier they've already played
against some outstanding midfield
players in this
competition so we've got trust in all of
our players
that's that's why we've selected them um
we've known that in any situation we'd
be happy to put any of them on the field
we've put some really young players into
into matches that um had a high profile
potentially uh quite a lot of tension
and pressure
they've all they've all dealt with that
really well and
we've had some senior players coming
back from injury that
that have contributed you know really
importantly as well
so um this effort has been about the
whole squad and that will continue into
tomorrow now for harry um you've been
part of this
journey pretty much very ever since the
beginning
obviously you're england captain you're
part of that semi-final and you're one
of the players to have played in
semi-finals and finals since then
but you've also got a number of your
teammates who are club captains
for their respective size like you think
of jordan henderson maguire
connor cody jack grealish how important
is that to the group having these
leaders
and having these players who have played
semi-finals and finals going into this
game
yeah that's a massive strength of ours
as a squad i feel you know
um yeah as the captain it's not an easy
job but it's definitely made easier when
uh you have the types of leaders around
you because it's not just one voice we
have
many voices like the the manager said
that that helped
out during games um after games before
games
um and that's a huge part of of a
successful team so
um yeah of course we wouldn't be where
we are without
all those players and i think they've
given a real
uh good vision for for the younger
players in the squad as well
and um yeah every big game that you play
you want as much experience as possible
and then like
like i said we definitely have that so
um yeah it's going to play an important
role
um obviously tomorrow and the future of
this team as well